why is it certain businesses can hover
above their competition
I mean his Starbucks really serving the
best cup of coffee I mean to want and to
be ambitious and to want to be
successful is not enough
very often the thing that actors tend to
do is I think they tend to focus on the
wrong thing and every time I take on
something the only thing that interests
me is what scares me he's an American
actor film director producer comedian
and singer he began his career as a
stage actor in the 1980s since 2013 he's
played Frank Underwood on the Netflix
series house of cards for which is won
numerous awards he's Kevin Spacey and
here's my take on his top 10 rules for
success rule number 8 is my personal
favorite I make sure to stick around all
the way to the end for some special
bonus clips also as Kevin is talking if
he says something that really is
meaningful to you make sure to write it
down in the comments below and put
quotes around it so others can be
inspired as well what we all are in the
business of storytelling I mean it's not
just exclusive for people like me who
are in the entertainment business I
think that no matter what business
you're in no matter what you're you're
selling or doing why is it certain
businesses can hover above their
competition I mean is Starbucks really
serving the best cup of coffee maybe not
I mean I like a caramel macchiato myself
but his American Express really the best
return rate on a credit card mm-hmm
probably not but it's the story they
managed to tell and I think that the
more that we think about that the more
that we you know sometimes you we see
commercials and we see stuff and we just
go eyes so you need to turn off that
somehow those people that managed to
tell a story that managed to even
temporarily move us in a certain way
that we remember we don't feel like
we're being sold we feel like we're
being told something that we can connect
to so I've always been driven by that
very idea that very notion can we help
us appreciate this early experience
these lean years these very difficult
years leading up to
the ultimate prize there is no prize out
there the only prize is this one and
what you feel and what you want to
accomplish and if you can as you start
out these what could be Linear's or
could be fat hairs
I feel that I very often watch a lot of
young people sort of meander around
without any idea about why they're doing
what they're doing
I mean to want and to be ambitious and
to want to be successful is not enough
that's just desire to know what you want
to understand why you're doing it to
dedicate every breath in your body to
achieve if you feel you have something
to give if you feel that your particular
talent is worth developing is worth
caring for
then there's nothing you can't achieve
and I think that when I was beginning as
an actor I was fortunate to have gone to
Juilliard when I did go study drama with
a great number of actors and actresses
who were going on to become very
well-known very quickly and I wasn't and
I think the sort of greatest lesson I
came out of about that was that
comparing yourself to other people is a
real mistake I mean my struggle wasn't
any worse or less or whatever than
anyone else's it was just mine I think
the audition process is no different
than going for a meeting as a
cinematographer or if you want to be in
any of the of the disciplines of this
industry very often the thing that
actors tend to do is I think they tend
to focus on the wrong thing so if I were
to say to you what do you think the
purpose of an audition is what was your
answer be what's the purpose of an
audition to live truthfully in the
moment very nice most people would say
to get the job all right now that is a
very very very dangerous place to start
to want to get the job now look let's
face facts if you get the job how great
that's great it's icing on the cake it's
fantastic but I believe that if actors
were better willing to adopt a
philosophy that it is an opportunity to
walk into a room and to begin a
relationship that may not pay off with
that particular job sometimes actors are
so nervous and they want that job so
much or they can't pay their rent they
gotta get that jonovic hi I'm time
well we see that you know the director
sees that so the problem with that is
that you're not being yourself you can't
be truthful in the moment when your
focus is on the result instead of what
on that day at that moment is the
beginning of a process can I work with
this actor the director is thinking does
this actor pay attention do they listen
and when I give them direction do they
actually change anything do they take
direction go that way and if you can
stand in a room and say I may be raw
I may be undeveloped I may have no
experience but I trust myself enough and
I believe in myself enough on this day
that I want to introduce myself to this
director casting director producer
assistant and by the way be really nice
to the assistants because no one behind
that table is any different than you
everyone behind that table is just as
ambitious as you are that director wants
to be doing better things that casting
director wants to be a director that
assistant that assistant wants to be the
casting director everybody wants to be
somewhere else in ten years just like
you do so we're all in the same boat and
it's sometimes hard to believe this no
matter how rude they might be no matter
how you knows because some of them are
just there in those kind of situations
but my point is this they're on your
side because they have to cast this
thing and because people are
fundamentally lazy they'd rather be home
smoking pot and watching TV
so
they want you to be good they want you
to solve their problem and too often I
think people don't realize that you have
to take the long view the short view is
I'm at this job any of these job I want
this job the long view is I have a
chance to meet someone I may admire
someone I could work with but I may not
be right for this job on this day that
has nothing to do with my talent
it could be a thousand reasons why you
don't get a job but if I'm good enough
if I stand on that stage and I show them
where my talent is on this day I walk
out that door they might look at each
other and go she's really good she's
really good she's not right for this but
she's really good and the next time they
do a film or the next time they do a
play they'll bring you back and someday
along that long road you may get that
job but it's about relationships and
it's about trusting yourself and where
you are and realizing you are good
enough for where you are right now on
that day and I believe in the long view
and I also believe that audiences have
remarkable attention spans you know
there's always this sort of argument you
sometimes see it in the way movies are
cut where there's a cut every three
seconds because god forbid something
isn't happening on screen something
isn't distracting but if you go back and
look at the great movies there's just a
camera
capturing people in a space that is
compelling and I believe audiences
actually at the end of the day they
don't care about platforms don't care
that it's on Netflix or on Instagram or
of a six-second vine or a 13 hour
miniseries on PBS they want good stories
if we give them great content not just
to fill the time but great content that
a great stories they will watch it on
whatever platform it's on but there is
something different in a story a
complexity that's possible obviously
with time
and do you think that there is if you
like a swing back against short snappier
bite-sized pieces of content to
something that is much more textured no
I actually think there's room for all of
it and I think that that's why we're
seeing so many different kinds of
platforms emerge you know people are
adapting storytelling for the platform
that they're on and that's actually kind
of exciting and opening up new doors I
travel I play a lot of tennis I play a
lot of ping-pong I see a lot of friends
and make a lot of dinners I enjoy my
life in fact in the last seven years
I've carved out more time for me then I
think ever before in my life I think you
have to I think it's hugely important to
be able to balance your life with your
work
I'm loving living life and I think it's
just hugely important I'm fortunate I
you know don't have a nine-to-five job
but this job does require an enormous
amount of my attention and I live
full-time in London and I only leave
London if I'm going to make a movie but
even if I'm able to carve out you know
two hours in the middle of the afternoon
to go play tennis or go to a gallery or
take a walk that's hugely valuable you
know even a two-day weekend can feel
like a five-day holiday you've worked
with unbelievable directors and and
other actors and great work Mamet's work
O'Neill can you just talk about that at
all about the collaboration or about the
way these well I mean that is that is it
I mean that is the key to to doing
anything and doing it well either in
film or in theater you know it's about
bringing all the elements together and
if you are fortunate enough to not be
driven by your own ego and not believe
that all your ideas are the only good
ones and are open to suggestion and to
criticism that's not a good idea
don't play it that way that doesn't
serve the writing as long as as actors
and to a large degree directors our job
is to serve the writer
serve the writing if you serve the
writing you will ultimately serve
yourself I think we have gone through a
couple of decades where actors have been
spending more time serving themselves
and they have forgotten that it is about
the writing it is about finding out the
world that a writer wants to create and
doing everything you can to give a
director as many choices as they
possibly can have an editing and
collaborating and being open about it
and loving that aspect of it because
it's so incredible if you a trust the
people that you work with and and bring
an atmosphere of openness and humor to
the proceedings so that everybody wants
to come to work every day and do their
best job so it is about collaboration
there's lots of films that people know
you know that that are always sort of
mentioned as you know wasn't that your
favorite and I'd hope I haven't done it
yet and every time I take on something
the only thing that interests me is what
scares me the only thing that interests
me is what I think I can't do well when
you're doing the TV show you know every
day is a different day in the sense that
it's never the same and you might be
shooting two scenes you might have one
scene you might have five scenes so your
level of preparation is different every
time
generally I'm up early I exercise I run
I do whatever it is I'm doing in terms
of my physical life other than playing
tennis which I I you know stack up
during the course of a week quite a lot
of if I can and you know get to set
depending on your call time but very
often is very early and then you you
know try to be there and be alert and
awake and alive and ready to go every
hour of the day and if you work 12 hours
then you have to be alert every one of
those hours um it's it's an important
thing to stay focused when someone has
the gift
I cannot resist I am told that you are
so adept at it if our audience closes
its eyes they will actually have the
impression that I am privileged to
interview some people who might
otherwise never have appeared on this
stage our guest is Jimmy Stewart and I
have this to urge any actors have
admired your naturalism and your
simplicity now is that just Jimmy
Stewart or is it Jimmy Stewart playing a
kind of Jimmy Stewart
well not not Jimmy I know I know what
you're saying
I'm aware of what you're trying to say
and the answer is yes
you can all testify now to the fact that
I have interviewed Jimmy Stewart now
Here I am this is after all a kind of
interview show a talk show and Johnny
you reigned for years as king of talk
show hosts or now we're talking what was
the secret of your success
you know Jimmy I'd love to answer that
but I don't work on Mondays
now I understand that you have conducted
a long correspondence with a Kevin
Spacey and that he approached you once
miss Hepburn and I would like to know
whether what's that story if you
actually correspond what you write is a
stalker
it just won't leave me alone
well when when he writes to you what do
you respond he writes letters goes on
and on about himself and I just say good
for you
I would like to ask at least because you
are a very good director as well as a
wonderful actor mr. Eastwood what is the
just a word of advice for our many
directors out there in our school well
I'd say get it done by 4:00 so you can
hit the links mr. Gielgud the rights
Rach
mr. Gielgud American actors envy you
your impeccable diction how did you
acquire it yeah went to school you know
trained for years and years
Marlon English actors English actors do
not admire your diction how did you
acquire it could it buy any
by any chance has been a result of your
training at the Actors Studio listen I
didn't learn diddly [ __ ] at the Actors
Studio
and frankly I'm just sick and tired of
all you cats just living off my name
forever so leave me alone and bring me
the Dorito mr. Walken you you are you
are despite book has just said a
distinguished member of the Actors
Studio and this is your second time on
this stage you have a response for for
Marlon well you know he's just stoned
you know you got a forgive him you know
he's crazy that way
I'm going to call on another member of
the Actors Studio distinguished member
of the Actors Studio to respond mr.
Pacino
you've already been immortalized by by
Kevin Spacey on Saturday Night Live we
all said saw that that how did you feel
about it to do were you pleased Oh funny
didn't bother at all no can I get a
cappuccino
I know that like so many of our students
who remember your evening here on this
stage with us Kevin Spacey often looks
to you Jack Lemmon for a professional
wisdom what is your final word tonight
what is your advice story on me I wish
the hell he stopped calling me leave me
alone
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Dante DeLuca
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the 10
rules the biggest impact on you what
change you're going to make as a result
of watching this video leave it in the
comments and I will join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Ana Weber from
successfully published calm and I thank
you so much for buying my book really
means a lot to me those are you who want
to chance it as China and some bonuses
in a future video make sure to pick up a
copy of the book and email in your
receipts that would keep track thank you
guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is I don't see you soon
I can tell you the moment I did the very
first thing in drama class where we had
to do a pantomime to music then I
created a Western scene where I was I
was riding a horse
I had a six-gun and it was to the music
from Dueling Banjos Baird of course the
ride got faster and faster as I went and
everybody applauded and laughed I was
like well that's a sound and then the
drama teacher there who was really
remarkable and a great mentor then led
me toward a workshop that was being run
by one of my idols which was Jack Lemmon
I mean his work in some like it hot or
the apartment or The Odd Couple some of
the finest work I'd ever seen he just
did comedy and drama brilliantly he was
he was a kind of everyman so he was
running this workshop at the Mark Taper
Forum in 1974 and I got a chance to go
and one of things we had to do is we had
do scenes and mr. Lemmon was going to
critique our scenes and so I did a scene
man you know I was very shy I was very
nervous I and he came up to me after I
did my sandy put his hand on my shoulder
and he said that was a chatty terrific
you should know I'm not kidding did you
what's your name I said Kevin he said
this young actor has just been doing
what I've been talking about all
afternoon you was connected to the
material you'd you're too Ryu I'm
telling you that you should go to New
York and you should study be an actor
because this is what you were meant to
do with your life and I was 13 years old
and it is kind of extraordinary that
sometimes in life teacher a parent an
adult a mentor can say just the right
words to a young person at just the
right moment and it can be life changing
and it was life changing for me because
I did go to New York I did study at
Juilliard for two years and then I began
my career as an actor in the theatre in
New York and then 12 years later after
we had met in 1974 I found out that Jack
Lemmon was coming to Broadway to do a
production of Eugene O'Neill's long
day's journey in tonight and I felt at
26 I was the right age to play one of
his sons and I particularly wanted to
play the role of the alcoholic Jamie
Tyrone so I tried and tried and tried
and tried to get an audition I couldn't
get an audition I finally had to sort of
sneak my way in and I finally got an
audition with Jonathan Miller who was
going to direct the production the great
British director and then I had to
audition with Jack and so once again
after we had met 12 years before I found
myself in a room with Jack Lemmon doing
the scene or we did like four scenes
together and I was relentless with him I
mean I prepared for this audition unlike
anything I've ever prepared for I was
toppling over his lines I was pushing
him oh I wanted this part so bad and at
the end of it Jack Lemmon once again
walked up to me put his hand on my
shoulder I said that was attached a
terrific
because you know what I never thought we
find the rotten kid but you're Jesus
Christ what the hell was that
and I won the role and I got to spend
the next year of my life working on
stage with my idol and he then became
the greatest mentor I could have hoped
to have had a father figure and really
somebody who was such an extraordinary
example of a man who had reached
absolute the heights in his profession
but it never went to his head
he's a sweetest man and we then ended up
doing three films together ending with
Glengarry Glen Ross which he used to
love to call gene Barry Glenn Close it's
easier to shed and you know there's
really not a day that goes by where the
influence he had the lessons he just by
example that he taught um I've always
sort of gone through my life feeling
like if I just keep a little twist of
lemon in my heart then I'm gonna be okay
we were talking about this outside in
the hallway about you know do you what
because we're talking about Shawn about
how sometimes you you can love what you
do
and be good at it but sometimes you
don't have to love what you do and still
be good at that's shown in acting yeah
we were to having this discussion out
there and I and and right now you know
not everything is great you know I
certainly want things I fight for things
to be better and I fight to do things
better in myself but I also feel like
I've been given so much opportunity to
even start to whiff of a sort of wine or
complain as certain other people do I
know whining complaining and complaining
hosts the I feel that it's listen to my
song someone like that I shoot a movie I
smack that's right but I I so I feel
like I the best thing that I can do is
be grateful and honor it and continue to
try to do the best work I can and and
I'm fortunate that you know every time
you know someone says oh no he's not the
right guy for that and I'm
to go out and and prove that I can do it